[Musique]
artaud nathalie 52 ans candidate lutte
ouvrière pour la troisième fois c'est
donc votre adn que nous allons tenter de
capter en vous plongeant dans les
archives de l'ina bonjour et bienvenue
nathalie arthaud bonjour la première
fois vous apparaissez à la télévision
c'est un gréviste déjà enseignante
grévistes mobilisés contre la réforme
fillon en 2003 et pour votre future
retraite
je vais partir à la retraite au delà de
2020 donc il faudra que 10 jusqu'à 68
ans puisque j'ai commencé à travailler à
26 ans et je partirai avec 30% de mon
salaire net vous militez depuis
l'adolescence 17 18 ans depuis 18 ans
depuis 18 ans surtout et et pourquoi
avoir choisi lutte ouvrière c'est vrai
que moi dès l'âge de 16 ans 17 ans
j'étais quand même révolté parce que je
voyais j'étais révoltée par par les
injustices part par la faim dans le
monde aussi il y avait eu en 86 une
famine en éthiopie enfin voila je ne me
voyais pas ne rien faire voilà tout
simplement jeu pour moi c'était ce
n'était pas possible d'accepter ça je
voyais bien je voyais bien que ici en
france les poubelles regorger etc
comment laisser ces enfants ces femmes
mourir de faim je ne comprenais pas et
donc ma première impulsion s'était
finalement de d'aller vers les
associations humanitaires et puis au
lycée à lyon je suis parti faire un
sport études à lyon j'ai rencontré des
jeunes des jeunes qui avaient des idées
qui avait des idées communistes qui
m'ont fait découvrir
donc le manifeste du parti communiste
qui m'ont fait découvrir les idées
révolutionnaires et qui m'ont fait
découvrir aussi la force du mouvement
ouvrier ça c'est quelque chose que
vraiment j'ai découvert parce que
j'étais moi même issu d'un milieu plutôt
commerçants agricole et puis tu vois la
rural et
j'ai découvert donc cette force là qui
avait déjà tellement fait pour faire
avancer la société et donc je me suis
cela m'a convaincu cela m'a convaincu à
l'époque il y avait le parti communiste
mais qui venait de gouverner qui venait
de gouverner qui était pour moi un parti
de gouvernement qui avait finalement qui
était dans le système donc non moi je
cherchais un parti attaché a vraiment
changé la société de fond en comble ça
devait être un parti révolutionnaire et
et cela a été les ouvrières quelques
mois après cette mobilisation de 2003
contre la réforme des retraites on vous
retrouve sur un plateau de télévision
pour interpeller le ministre de
l'éducation de l'époque luc ferry
vous voulez lutter contre l'illettrisme
et 100 employés de professeurs alors
j'aimerais bien savoir comment ça se
fait sentir un peu la voix c'est pas
possible je veux dire aussi par rapport
aux postes budgétaires je pense que de
l'argent quand vous vous en trouvez vous
en trouvez en réalité à la du jour au
lendemain quand même vous avez trouvé
500 millions pour payer la monde du
crédit lyonnais oui c'est votre
gouvernement le gouvernement dans lequel
poussette pour qu'ils puissent continuer
de faire des affaires d'ailleurs qui ne
fonctionne pas bien vous êtes en zone en
allusion à l'affairé executive life qui
a effectivement coûté cher à l'état
comme les autres passifs du du lyonnais
quels souvenirs gardez-vous de ce moment
peut-être la première fois vous avez pu
interpeller directement un ministre oui
ça c'est sûr j'en garde un souvenir très
fort c'était à la sorbonne et
s'était passé c'était extrêmement
stressant pour moi parce que je portais
aussi finalement tous ceux qui s'étaient
battus tous ceux qui avaient fait grève
et j'avais envie
vraiment de l'est
de les représenter et qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient fiers finalement de ce que
je pouvais porter la danse est dans
cette émission donc pour moi voilà je
m'en souviens comme une grosse
responsabilité déjà à l'époque et ça
avait été difficile j'étais très tendu
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les draps les
images soient pas le stress
ainsi si on voit la veine qui désigne un
stress évident à lilith et lutte
ouvrière comporte un certain nombre de
rituels le plus connu est la fête de l
eau chaque week-end de pentecôte dans le
domaine de bellevue à presles dans le
val d'oise voici un aperçu télévisée de
la fête de 89
[Musique]
il fait la dix neuvième du genre jusqu'à
demain soir une centaine de mouvements
de libération de partis politiques de
gauche représente ici les cinq
continents car la fête de lutte ouvrière
c'est également cela pêle mêle musique
kermesse et discussions politiques et
bien sûr le chantre des travailleurs
l'éternel laguilliez l'europe oui mais
l'europe des travailleurs pour la tête
de liste de lutte ouvrière qui tente
aujourd'hui sa troisième percée au
parlement européen après 79 et 84 une
nouvelle tentative sans trop d'illusions
mais qui n'empêche pas une pointe
d'humour
il martèle que le patronat doit pas
connaître parce que ça augmente les
rendements
là
au moins nous
[Musique]
ce sera
avez vous déjà raté une fête de l'eau
non
jamais ça me rend très fort pour pour
pour moi et pour nous tous je crois
parce que c'est aussi un moment de
fraternité très fort c'est aussi vous
savez cette fête nous mettons cinq six
semaines pour pour la montée c'est le
fruit du travail de centaines de
militants qui mettent tout leur coeur
leur passion leurs compétences etc et
rien que pour nous ça c'est déjà une
petite fierté et de voir ce qu'on arrive
à faire au final et comment chacun a à
coeur de voilà de de faire le meilleur
pour pour passer ces trois journées
ensemble
défendre nos idées défendre aussi voilà
la perspective d'une autre société
d'autres rapports humains aussi etc
c'est tout ça pour moi la fête c'est
toujours un moment où on emmagasine a
beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup d
enthousiasme pour repartir au combat et
voici à présent le passage de témoin en
2007 vous êtes la porte parole d'ard
d'arlette laguiller pour sa dernière
candidature présidentielle et vous vous
apprêtez à prendre la relève
travailleuses travailleurs camarades et
amis à force de campagne elle a
transformé sa popularité en succès dans
les urnes en 95 et 2002 elle dépasse par
deux fois la barre des 5% mais ce
capital sympathie arlette laguiller va
devoir le transmettre et parmi les
successeurs possibles mises en lumière
dans ce parti où on cultive le secret
nathalie arthaud 37 ans porte parole de
lutte ouvrière dans la région lyonnaise
les à l'entendre rien n'est fait à l'âge
la compagne parce qu'on est en meeting à
lyon quant aux présidentielles c'est
dans cinq ans donc là vraiment je crois
qu'on a le temps de voir tout ça donc
c'est pas vraiment d'actualité pour
l'instant
sourire complice bienveillant et même
une forme de mimétisme un peu de
ressemblance physique entre vous donnant
oui alors ça c'est pas qu'on m'en dire
ses proches ouah c'est voilà ça se
trouve comme ça on avait
mais vous savez quand tous ceux qui
connaissent le tour hier savent qu'on
est très différent quand des très divers
qu'on est voilà donc bon pour moi non
c'est pas bon maintenant en même temps
il ya une simplicité c'est sûr que moi
je n'ai jamais porté de bisous j'ai
jamais eu cette envie là
j'étais ou alors me qualifier de garçon
manqué
dans ma jeunesse et puis j'ai toujours
eu envie de faire ce que faisait les
garçons d'ailleurs aussi c'est une
réalité voilà moi j'ai jamais j'ai
toujours eu envie
voilà des d'avoir j'ai toujours aspiré à
cette égalité là donc vous voyez
c'est ça ce jeu je pense que ça fait
partie aussi de beaucoup de
militants aient compris de féministes en
tout cas nous n'avons pas eu à chercher
très loin pour trouver votre mentor
[Musique]
avec la guye et bien sûr 39 ans passés à
porter la parole de lutte ouvrière six
fois candidate à la présidentielle
record absolu on dit que vous vous
partagez aujourd'hui encore le même
bureau qu'elle relie certains de vos
discours qu'elle vous conseille c'est
vrai vous confirmez ah oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai on partage le même bureau on
discute beaucoup elle elle me transmet
son
son expérience et puis et puis aussi on
discute on discute de la situation
réagit on partage aussi notre colère moi
je fus impressionné
tous les jours de de voir avec quelle
quelle quelle fraîcheur
arlette reste reste révolté quoi voilà
elle et elle est révoltée moi je
la différence d'âge je ne la sens
absolument pas je je il y à toujours
aller à nîmes est toujours de 2 de cette
même force de cette même force de se
dire mais oui cette société on peut la
changer on peut faire mille fois mieux
c'est pas voilà on marche sur la tête
enfin voilà donc c'est que vraiment
c'est un partage c'est un partage je
pense que un partage sur un aussi un
pied d'égalité parce qu'on est militante
toutes les deux voilà donc
c'est alors quand vous a préparé un
petit florilège de ses années de toutes
ces années arlette dans les meetings et
à la télévision avec un un bonus rares
d'abord sa toute première apparition
dans un reportage ou simple voyageuse à
la sortie du métro elle dénonce le
scandale des transports en commun vous
prenez le métro le matin par exemple
vous voyez des femmes avec des gosses en
émettront on est absolument bousculer
ciré elles sont obligées dominé leurs
gosses dans une crèche par exemple là
c'est absolument scandaleux qu'on fasse
voyager les gens dans des conditions
pareilles 170 candidats ils sont tous
des trains ouvriers techniciens employés
qui minent et du quotidiennement dans
leur entreprise qui sont des militants
syndicaux qui participent aux luttes de
la classe ouvrière
travailleuses travailleurs
c'est à vous que je m'adresse
particulièrement ce soit eh bien oui je
suis une femme et j'ose me présenter
comme candidate à la présidence de cette
république d'homme c'est légal et
pourtant cela choque cela paraît étrange
même aux hommes de gauche et cela doit
l'être puisque je suis la seule petite
fille modèle audio et l'ordre
je vivais dans un quartier ouvrier avec
pleins pleins d'enfants qui ont joué
dans le jardinet qu'entouraient le petit
immeuble que j'habitais et je vous
laisse j'ai aimé les jeux mais je crois
que déjà j'avais un certain goût pour la
lecture c'est vrai aussi en tout cas je
ne regrette pas de m'être présenté bien
au contraire ce que j'ai dit dans cette
campagne a été au moins 10 par quelqu'un
et si les travailleurs ne sont que s'en
souvenir dans les mois qui viennent je
dis c'est déjà important celle
là
pour nous
[Musique]
là
bon on a compris que vous aussi vous la
voulez qui fait par
arlette dans le prénom était plus connu
que son parti vous êtes déjà demandé
nathalie arthaud pourquoi l épave ou en
tout cas vous un peu moins non jamais
jamais parce que la réponse est très
simple elle est très simple
effectivement la première femme à se
présenter en 74 ça a été un coup de
tonnerre moi je crois voilà et en plus
elle était la première donc à se
présenter à la présidentielle mais elle
venait de conduire une grande grève dans
le secteur bancaire et j'étais aussi
fait connaître à partir à partir de ce
moment là donc c'est toute une période
d'une période de combat sur sur tous les
plans à la fois des combats de
travailleurs des combats aussi féministe
donc c'est toute cette période là cette
lutte aussi contre la guerre d'algérie
parce que c'est aussi ça l'histoire
d'arles est elle s'est engagée à ce
moment là donc donc oui c'est une
période de politisation intense où les
femmes sont sont à l'avant et je crois
qu arlette elle elle représente ça donc
moi j'arrive après j'arrive après
avec les scores que
que vous n'avez pas atteint les scores
d'arlette la guyane dépasser 5% à la
présidentielle en 95 et 2002 mais vous
voyez elle s'est présentée en 74 la
première fois il a fallu fallu attendre
95 pour que ye 5% et en fait c'est aussi
95 je pense une période où finalement il
y avait déjà une petite remontée
d'un esprit contestataire dans le monde
du travail d'ailleurs ça ensuite il ya
eu les grandes grèves de 95 contre le
plan juppé enfin ça a été un moment
important où il ya eu des millions de
salariés qui se sont manifestés qui ont
fait grève un vrai bras de fer et j'ai
l'impression que cette élection de 95
était finalement
annoncé cet cette remontée de conscience
ouvrière finalement votre mentor
originel si je puis dire celui qui a
créé la matrice politique de votre
mouvement c'est léon trotsky
révolutionnaire russe devenu opposant à
staline qui le fera assassiner voici la
voix de trotski deux ans avant sa mort
octobre 1938 il est en exil au mexique
et il vient de créer la quatrième
internationale
ils prêts
arnaud est parti al ahd et repart
en piste il note en it were more members
mort peppers marmonner des très jolies
mort des petits audard inédit
avec 1000
m ils défaut matériel
perry qui a libéré
les dettes sociales ou
auriez bien plus petit nombre divion
khalip épouse suite le ministre
a dit
nouri et à
personne d'autre que nous pour faire la
révolution dit trotsky que fait-il dire
en disant cela que les autres formes de
luttes ne sont pas légitimes au efficace
non pas du tout c'est simplement que il
faut avoir cette conscience que le
levier
révolutionnaire pour contester la classe
capitaliste qui aujourd'hui monopolise
toutes les décisions en fait qui
décident à notre place finalement de 2
comment ce qu'on doit produire ou avec
avec qui dans quelles conditions et qui
engagent l'avenir de l'humanité je
dirais de la planète c'est cette classe
capitaliste et comment peut-on faire
pour la contester comment peut-on faire
pour pour
finalement pour la renverser pour la
renverser parce que moi je pense que
c'est ce qu'il faut et bien moi je pense
que c'est simplement
en partant de cette de cette idée que
les travailleurs le l'ensemble du monde
du travail quand je parle de
travailleurs il faut bien réaliser que
cela va des ouvriers de ceux qui sont
tout en bas de la hiérarchie jusqu'aux
ingénieurs jusque
au cadre aussi ce sont eux qui les font
tourner ces entreprises ce sont eux qui
créent toutes ces richesses sont eux qui
créent les profits les dividendes les
capitaux aussi d'ailleurs que cette
grande bourgeoisie s'arroge et que ce
sont eux qui seront capables de dire eh
bien écoutez maintenant on dirige
maintenant nous décidons finalement nous
prenons un tas de décisions
confronté au problème de la réalité au
problème de la production fait le plus
difficile on peut aussi fixé nous mêmes
les objectifs fixés la politique de ces
multinationales et la politique tout
court voilà donc en fait il n'y a pas
d'autres leviers que l'ensemble des
travailleurs qui représentent
l'écrasante majorité de la population
d'ailleurs pour changer la société de
fond en comble voilà moi je ne crois pas
du tout à la possibilité que comment
dire une
une catégorie comme ça fasse le bonheur
là où un homme puisse faire le bonheur à
le puisse faire le bonheur de tous
changer la société ça sera l'oeuvre de
deux millions de milliards d'êtres
humains en réalité ce sera leur activité
ce sera l'heure leur engagement la
révolution comme but ultime
ça veut dire que le reste les luttes
sociales les élections c'est secondaire
adieu à ses c'est certain que ce ne sont
pas dans les élections que le sort des
opprimés le sort des exploités peut
avancer et ça c'est quand même c'est
toute l'histoire le montre toute
l'histoire le montre toutes les avancées
sociales la moindre en fait avancé
social a été le fruit d'un rapport de
force voilà était le fruit de luttes
sociales d'explosion sociale
d'insurrection de révolution alors voilà
et jamais en fait tout ça n'est jamais
tombé du haut de l'elysée ou de je ne
sais quelle institution ça a été
toujours l'oeuvre finalement des
travailleurs eux mêmes et ça oui ça fait
partie des choses que moi je tiens à
dire dans cette campagne et je pense
qu'on appelle d'ailleurs à a voté à dire
ben finalement on est conscient de cela
on est conscient que que les choses
changeront si si si nous repartons nous
mêmes au combat si on s'organise ici
donc moi c'est cette politique là que je
veux autour de laquelle je veux
rassembler a semblé y compris dans cette
élection présidentielle alors à propos
de rapports de force et en attendant une
révolution qui ne sera pas un dîner de
gala comme comme l'a dit mao il arrive
que la lutte politique s'exerce dans la
violence ou la contrainte exemple avec
cette figure de lutte ouvrière en
picardie que vous connaissez roland
szpirko filmé par les caméras d'envoyé
spécial en 95
ben vous entendez comme 1 écoutez bien
nous avons décidé d'occuper la direction
nationale de la npa avant de montrer au
gouvernement qu'il doit répondre à notre
exigence aucun salarié de chansons à la
npa
cette occupation est pacifique les
salariés qui travaillent à ne sont pas
nos ennemis le bouffer filet nous votre
badge
ainsi on n'a pas tout vous croisez le
louvre et puis c'est tout vous préférez
qu'on casse
tu cherches aidé par leila ma forme
[Musique]
non
très déterminés prêts à rester le temps
qu'il faut pour rester longtemps
roland szpirko dans la lutte des
chaussons de lille mr sow sont super
image il vous est arrivé vous d'employer
ses méthodes mais enfin j'ai une petite
question là où est la violence
violence je vois zéro violence massy là
où je vois la violence c'est dans la
fermeture de chaussons là je la vois la
violence je vois des milliers de
familles ouvrières qui vont être plongés
dans la misère qui je vois des
travailleurs qui ont passé leur vie
qu'ils ont peut-être laissé leur santé
un pur pour chaussons dans et pour tous
pour toutes ses usines je les vois est
remis
être être être être mis dehors quoi et
là c'est de la violence et vous savez
d'ailleurs la picardie l'aisne le nord
regardez c'est désert industriel
regarder cette misère et cette précarité
aujourd'hui qui est d'une violence mais
alors extrême moi je pense que la
première violence c'est ça c'est la
misère c'est la misère c'est le fait de
ne même pas pouvoir gagner sa vie dans
cette société même pas avoir ce droit là
mais là dans les images non je vois
absolument zéro violence est par
ailleurs moi ça mais moi ça me ça me
fait même je vais vous dire ça me fait
rêver ça ah oui ils s'invitent sur à
pôle emploi il s'invite sur les plateaux
de télé il s'invite sur les
champs-elysées et moi je pense que oui
les les tous ceux qui sont opprimés et
bien ils doivent s'inviter sans quoi ce
en quoi bon on est voué à être les
éternels sacrifiés on n'existe pas en
fait on est même invisible on est même
invisible donc bah oui voilà il faut qu
on s'invite comme les gilets jaunes oui
comme le gilet jaune mais je dirais
encore plus que ça parce que moi je
pense que
ce mouvement d gilet jaune au moment où
il m'a conforté il m'a conforté dans
cette
conviction profonde que la capacité de
révolte elle est intacte dans la société
et qu'elle peut venir de femmes et
d'hommes que con qu'on n'imagine pas
qu'on n'imagine pas parce qu'ils ne sont
pas organisés ils n'ont jamais fait de
syndicalisme parce que ils sont jamais
comment dire associé à différents voilà
aux luttes précédentes mais n'empêche
que ils peuvent aussi être amené à se
battre sur ce terrain est à chercher
l'organisation justement mais je pense
enfin moi mon combat par rapport à tout
ça c'est que la lutte elle rentre aussi
dans les entreprises au coeur même du
système dans ces fameuses citadelle
capitaliste là où il ya l'argent qui
secret mais là aussi où il ya ces
inégalités là où il ya cette souffrance
qui se créent et là où les décisions
sont prises où les décisions sont prises
et parce que c'est celle adveraires
véritable on aura un levier pour peser
sur la politique ne ces multinationales
de cette classe capitaliste donc voila
moi c'est ça ma politique mais mais oui
il faut il faut forcément se faire une
place il faut il faut utiliser cette
force collective parce que dans les
images ce qu'on voit c'est que si la
porte est ouverte au pied de biche cki
accros peuvent ils sont une cinquantaine
ou 60 derrière vouloir rentrer et a pas
vouloir se faire musbah pas vouloir se
a pas accepté un con con les musel voilà
il est temps d'établir taux de déterrer
vos racines
[Musique]
votre paysage d'enfance c'est un village
de la drôme perrin le métier de votre
père garagiste vous avez vous même servi
l'essence à la pompe paraît-il c'était
comment le métier de garagiste dans les
années 70 je vous propose cette archive
de
vraiment aimé garagiste à paris dans le
quartier de la république
concessionnaires de moto et agents d'une
marque de voitures françaises il emploie
six mécaniciens est il un parking de 200
places il a accepté de répondre aux
questions comme celle ci que nous nous
posons tous pourquoi les gens se
méfie-t-il des garagistes parce qu'il
sent souvent ont finalement mal reçue
deuxièmement parce qu'ils sont souvent
mal servi
surtout au niveau
des grosses affaires
tout simplement on est à un numéro sur
une voiture sur le toit d'une voiture
ensuite votre voiture monte à l'atelier
père furent celles vous connaît l'effet
dit donc c'est le même problème que pour
les grandes surfaces et les petits
commerçants le client n'a aucun lien
avec le mécanicien il peut pas lui
exposer ses petits malheurs ses petits
ennuis mais tout le monde ne peut pas
aller dans un petit garage
on vient dans un garage dans un petit
garage parce que le copain didier ben
hadid on va chez intel c'est un petit
garage et je le connais bien il est bien
t'en fais pas et puis les pas trop cher
c'est surtout ça qu'on dit il et pas
trop cher ça ressemble à ce que vous
avez connu ça ressemble oui alors c'est
assez différent aussi parce que bon là
il s'agit d'un village
donc en fait quand on est garagiste dans
sedan 1-1 dans un village dans un milieu
rural en fait tout le monde se connaît
tout le monde se connaît ce sont des
liens des liens familiaux des liens
amicaux les enfants se connaissent enfin
bon évidemment quand on est garagiste
danser dans cette situation là on est
sous le contrôle permanent mois
moi j'ai en tête mon père qui recevait
un coup de fil voilà à 21h 22h j'ai fait
je suis je suis dans le fossé il faut
sortir la voiture viens avec ta viens
avec ta dépanneuse et mon père je vois
partir en pleine nuit avec la dépanneuse
pour aller sortir la voiture et puis
pour que le lendemain et puis on prétend
d'ailleurs une voiture de remplacement
parce que c'est c'est aussi tout ça qui
se passe dans
[Musique]
dans les garages de ces
deux de ces zones rurales donc oui alors
moi mon père il ya toujours eu les mains
effectivement
dans le cambouis dans le cambouis voilà
les mains qui a le zm m6 il employait
des ouvriers même si
il n'était pas tout seul à travailler
n'empêche qu'il a toujours été
effectivement bien plonger dans quoi
le déclic du
militantisme l'engagement vous avez
raconté qu'adolescente il est venu
d'image que vous avez vus à la
télévision nous sommes en 84 une famine
sévit en ethiopie qui fera des centaines
de milliers de morts et qui donnera lieu
à une mobilisation internationale avec
la chanson we are the world au
catéchisme vous êtes assidus vous fait
un collage de photos pour alerter sur ce
drame reportage terrible diffusé dans le
journal de 20 heures d'antenne 2
donc quelques ce bébé sera mort c'est
une certitude
comme celui là ils sont plus de 500
mille ans passés ici dans ces camps au
nord d'addis abeba
c'est l'ethiopie qui a fait de vaud une
militante ou la lecture de marx et
engels le manifeste du parti communiste
les deux en fait les deux en fait ça
fait ma révolte ça a fait mon mon envie
ma résolution que que cette société là
il fallait que je m'engage pour la
changer et puis la lecture de marx la
découverte du mouvement ouvrier cela m'a
donné les outils voilà le moyen de la
changer le moyen et voyez là on parle de
cette famine 84 86 etc mais ce qui est
fou c'est que les mêmes images on peut
les avoir aujourd'hui encore encore
aujourd'hui et ça c'est quelque chose
que je ne peux pas supporter on produit
pour deux fois la population de la
planète aujourd'hui il ya une personne
qui comptait une minute de malnutrition
toutes les dix secondes c'est le sait
c'est incroyable nous est agrégé
d'économie et de gestion vous avez
choisi l'enseignement l'informatique au
lycée albert camus dans la région
lyonnaise et puis au lycée le corbusier
à aubervilliers nous sommes en 2012 on
vous retrouve dans ce reportage du
journal télévisé
début du marathon mi-journée à
aubervilliers en seine-saint-denis
nathalie arthaud quitte le lycée
technique où elle enseigne
l'informatique en gestion
la porte parole de lutte ouvrière à
l'étiquette vu à la télé id trotsky sent
moins connu est né dé strauss kahn a
révolutionné les grossistes
je les ai entendus entre eux a les a
expliqués mais oui lutte ouvrière est
les communistes expliqué nathalie
arthaud ce choix de l'enseignement parce
que on sait car dit l'un des fondateurs
de lutte ouvrière recommandé tout
particulièrement aux adhérents le métier
de professeur car il permettait d'avoir
du temps libre pour militer c'est la
raison de votre choix est ce que vous
sentez plus plus militante
qu'enseignante houle inverse au les deux
en fait et c'est vrai que le métier
d'enseignant s'est passé pas le pire des
métiers dans cette société pourrie j'ai
envie de dire parce que quand même c'est
aussi un moyen de faire réfléchir de de
permettre à des jeunes d'apprendre
d'être maîtres de leur avenir je
développe voilà c'est une façon de
développer l'esprit critique enfin tout
ça pour moi c'est aussi des choses
importantes voilà
donc bon c'est s'est
fait assez naturellement en fait que je
me suis engagé de ce côté là et puis et
puis c'était voilà je pouvais concilier
justement les deux même si même si la
façon dont on nous demande d'enseigner
et de plus en plus finalement
frustrant frustrant mais ça comme dans
les hôpitaux un mois je je me dis
souvent que finalement un ce sentiment
que quand beaucoup d'un dead soignants
d'infirmières de 2,2 de salariés des
ehpad dans ce sentiment finalement des
dettes dans la maltraitance c'est
quelque chose que je ressens aussi dans
l'éducation en fait une grande figure de
l'histoire de france à présent invoqué à
tout bout de champ dans cette campagne
pas par vous mais à qui nous nous
invitons les candidats se confronter
c'est la rubrique face à de gaulle
[Musique]
pour vous nous avons choisi une archive
de 65 entre les deux tours de la
présidentielle où le général explique
par une drôle de métaphores nos
aspirations contradictoires à l'ordre et
au changement
dans une maison
la maîtresse de maison la ménagère
elle veut avoir un aspirateur d'avoir un
frigidaire
veut avoir une machine à laver
et même si c'est possible qu'on ait une
tôt
ça c'est le mouvement
en même temps elle veut pas que son mari
son amant gauche et
que les gars on met les pieds sur la
table et que les filles en attend pas la
nuit
sachez l'ordre
et la ménagère veut le progrès mais je
veux pas la pagaille
et bien c'est vrai aussi pour la france
il faut le progrès il faut pas la
pagaille le mouvement et l'ordre progrès
sans la pagaille vous trouvez cela abus
ou ou terriblement conserver ses
conservateurs de boutons vous là
franchement le mouvement c'est la
ménagère qui veut sa machine à laver
aujourd'hui je crois que les femmes
elles aspirent
à d'abord à ce que l'homme se s'occupe
des des lessives exactement comme elle
enfin bon non là je crois que on est
quand même on a encore progressé en
termes de libération
et de et de progressisme ya presque 60
au rebond on serait bien en peine
nathalie arthaud de trouver chez vous un
changement de ligne politique mais dans
l'histoire de lutte ouvrière il ya tout
de même eu un virage à 180 degrés
[Musique]
ce virage c'est celui de votre dirigeant
historique hardy robert barcia de son
vrai nom qui passe soudainement de
l'ombre à la lumière puisque le parti
garder une part de mystère et de
clandestinité les militants avaient des
blast des pseudonymes or voici qu'en
2003 hardy écrit un livre pour raconter
la vraie histoire de lutte ouvrière la
vie de l'intérieur il se dévoile et
témoigne dans un reportage diffusé au
journal de france 2
à lutte ouvrière tout est un peu
mystérieux en tout cas différent ce
n'est pas au siège de son parti que nous
avons rencontré robert barcia car de
siège il n'y en a pas c'est ici la
maison d'édition du journal lutte
ouvrière de même les congrès de ce
mouvement sont un peu particulier on
sait y compris dans la presse que c'est
le premier de ces chaque année le
premier week end de décembre et on peut
y assister ce que n'ont pas la presse
autre originalité les militants de lutte
ouvrière y compris la plus célèbre
d'entre eux n'aurait le droit ni de se
marier ni d'avoir des enfants alors nous
nous sommes pour la libération de la
femme et le mariage est une forme
d'aliénation d'afam nous disant un homme
camarades bon bah faut savoir que si tu
milites de telle façon tu veux avoir des
enfants des les problèmes en ayant des
gueuses le temps l'interdît pas
mariage et enfants des conseillers s'est
toujours mais non et d'ailleurs enfin
tous ceux qui nous connaissent savent
très bien que beaucoup de camarades ont
des enfants et même plusieurs voilà donc
mais après il y avait sept cette
détermination et c'est vrai car l'être
elle en a fait part elle de se rendre
complètement disponible pour son combat
par exemple pour moi c'est le choix que
j'ai eu envie de faire aussi j'ai eu
envie va justement de travailler pour
tous les enfants du monde moi c'est
comme ça que je le voyais aussi à bab
écouter on sais pas je n'ai pas relu mes
mais c'est ça ma conviction profonde et
c'est vrai que moi je me voyais pas
avoir une vie angers où je jeu
encore une fois moi je mon combat ce qui
m'anime ce qui me fait vivre à ses 7
cette idée qu'on peut faire autre chose
de la société voilà et après bon moi ça
me fait assez s'ouvrir tout ça parce que
bon des blazes des pseudonymes
franchement aujourd'hui tout le monde on
a les journalistes en ont
beaucoup sont reconnues oui bien sûr et
beaucoup sont connus sous d'ailleurs
deux des pseudonymes en fait donc donc
voilà à qui vous pensez à quoi je
pensais je pense à certains journalistes
d'ailleurs je suis allé il n'y a pas
bien longtemps dans une émission où
des journalistes m'ont expliqué que
quand il était rentré à europe 1 on leur
avait demandé de changer leur nom voilà
oui oui de changer leur nom de se
présenter sous un autre nom parce que ça
gênait
la direction d'europe alors voyez bon
alors bon tout ça ben oui alors et vous
le savez mieux que moi en fait donc vous
pouvez mieux l'expliquer que moi c'est
dit c'était pour des raisons de money
alors en réalité pour des raisons
d'homonymie mais pas seulement mais pas
seulement parce que le nom sonnait pas
suffisamment bien aux oreilles des
hommes ou des zones au mélo voilà alors
bar lourd secret à lui tout allait bien
ce secret ce secret c'est tu sais que
c'est un fantasme c'est un fantasme
parce que vous savez
tous les militants lutte ouvrière on est
prêt enfin comment dire on est des
militants qui allons vers la population
qui défendons nos convictions la
distribuer des tracts on anime des
réunions deux partout quand vous allez
voir notre activité sur notre site par
exemple puisque voilà eh bien on voit
qu'on est présent dans toutes les
régions d'ailleurs on se présente dans
tous les combats politiques
on a dix mille candidats aux municipales
donc donc donc voilà alors après les
congrès oui dans les congrès et dans nos
congrès là où on discute de nos affaires
là où tous les camarades sont présents y
compris ceux qui sont pourchassés par
leur direction parce qu'ils font du
syndicalisme parce que et qu'on ne veut
pas qu'ils soient connus comme lutte
ouvrière parce que sinon ils seraient à
la porte et bien notre congrès oui on
veut faire entre nous mais avant après
on a vite à nos conférences de presse on
rencontre des discussions et cetera donc
bon ça c'est un faux procès c'est un
faux procès qui est fait contre nous et
bon moi je vous savez arlette a expliqué
d'ailleurs dans un une image que vous
venez de montrer que nous méritons tous
les jours tous les jours dans les
quartiers populaires dans les
entreprises et ceux qui ont envie de se
battre les travailleurs qui ont envie de
se battre qu'ils ont envie de
s'organiser et bien voilà il vient en
fait ils savent qu'ils peuvent compter
sur nous et qu'on sera toujours là qu'on
est là et qu'on essaye nous on ne vise
qu'une seule chose c'est de faire
grossir ce parti communiste
révolutionnaire quand soit plus en plus
nombreux c'est ça notre notre notre
volonté rubrique suivante
[Musique]
alors 0 pointe est un accident de
parcours ou une parole qui détonne ici
pendant la campagne de 2010 est alors
que tous les candidats dresse messages
de soutien à emmanuel macron et françois
fillon qui ont qui sont visés par des
menaces terroristes qui sont sous
protection renforcée la faire vous
laisse de marbre
pas écouté est-ce qu'ils sont visés
directement je ne sais pas moi j'ai pas
bien compris
ce qu'ils sont
écoutés ils sont bien bien protégé 1
voilà je crois pas qu'ils attendent de
deux mois
0 compassion pour les adversaires
politiques non mais surtout si ridicule
de demander à nathalie arthaud et à
lutte ouvrière si vous voulez un soutien
ou je ne sais trop quoi enfin je veux
dire oui en fait tout ça c'est une
manoeuvre politicienne on veut
absolument me faire dire que je soutient
emmanuel macron que et ben j'ai pas
envie de le dire après moi qui vais le
protéger en réalité il a bien d'autres
protections est bien plus efficace
donc voilà je vous tout ça c'est c'est
la petite politique politicienne
pourquoi pourquoi pour que quand j'ai
cinq minutes d'émission je ne puisse pas
défendre mes idées de jeu ne puisse pas
défendre mon programme donc voila moi je
ne marche pas dans dans le jeu je tombe
pas dans le piège c'est tout vous savez
bon nous on a los teques des parrainages
c'est difficile on arrive à le passer
mais ensuite on a à l'obstacle de
pouvoir défendre notre point de vue sur
les plateaux télé et là je peux vous
dire que c'est un deuxième obstacle
parce que parce qu'en fait tout est fait
pour justement puisse pas développé ce
qu'on pense qu'on ne puisse pas dire
notre politique a on ne fait
qu'augmenter et ceci cela on fait réagir
à ce que peuvent dire les autres mais
voilà tout est fait pour que finalement
je me taise au fond 1 et que je je
m'efface derrière les grands candidats
voilà alors manon jeu
je me bagarre ça peut vous paraître
comment le dire
maladroit ou vous zéro pointé comme vous
voulez mais moi je me bagarre pour
défendre ma politique ce qui n'est pas
le cas ici
avec cet adn qu'on continue d'explorer
nathalie arthaud une madeleine quelque
chose de personnel à présent pour vous
[Musique]
william gardner smith et l'inde aux
écrivains préférés journaliste et
écrivain afro américain exide en france
dans les années 50 hauteur du visage de
pierre stone faith nous avons trouvé un
reportage sur lui diffusé en 64 banc des
actualités françaises
c'est souvent autour d'une bouteille de
côtes du rhône que se reconstituent à
l'heure du dîner un semblant d'ambiance
de harlem
le cuisinier leroy n 6 a pourvu en
amenant avec lui son barbecue
mais cela relève l'année qu'un fantôme
car en choisissant paris ils ont bien
souvent adopté la vie à la française
comme william gardin smith le romancier
pourquoi avez vous justement choisi la
france j'ai quitté les états unis à
cause de racisme je trouvais que je
pouvais vraiment tous travailler là bas
je sentais une violence monte à moi je
craignais vraiment que j'allais finir
par tuer quelqu'un pour nous les noirs
il ya beaucoup moins de racisme ici aux
etats unis william garde marc smith
pourquoi lui alors simplement j'ai lu
visage de pierre il ya pas très
longtemps et j'ai trouvé ce très très
très intéressant parce qu'effectivement
il explique
en france oui lui ils ne sont pas de
racisme vis-à-vis vis-à-vis des noirs
mais ce qu'il explique dans son dans son
roman visage de pierre c'est que ben on
est en pleine guerre d'algérie et le
racisme par contre ils le sont mais
alors puissance 1000 contre les
algériens contre les les musulmans et ça
ils l'expliquent pertinemment et ils se
retrouvent à un moment donné dans son
dans dans sa vie je pense que c'est un
moment de sa vie il a une rixe dans un
dans un bar justement avec avec un
algérien est là la police arrive pour
les séparent et cll les arrête tous les
deux et lui qui est noir est considéré
comme le blanc il a droit à tous les
honneurs à du monsieur et oui on vous
écoute et c'est quand l'algérien lui et
bien subi des humiliations si ce n'est
des ratonnades c'est ça la réalité et
lui il le voit et réalise que le racisme
qu'il a essayé de fuir en quittant les
états unis et bien existe ici existe ici
en plein coeur de paris
d'ailleurs il est témoin du 17 octobre
61 vous voyez alors voila moi j'ai
trouvé son roman très très très très
intéressant très intéressant et et moi
il m'a profondément touché et il me fait
réfléchir et me fait réfléchir et je
pense qu'il devrait faire réfléchir tout
le monde aujourd'hui parce que en fait
on n'en a pas fini avec ses démons là
une archive que nous soumettons à tous
les candidats celle de l' alerte verte
[Musique]
archives tiré de la campagne
présidentielle de 74 ou le tout premier
candidat écologiste casse le ronron
politique pour nous alerter sur des
dangers futur
vous savez ce qui va se passer eh bien
nous allons bientôt manquer de l'eau et
c'est pourquoi je bois devant vous un
verre d'eau précieuse puisque avant la
fin du siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera à lundi je
vous dis au revoir et j'espère vous
revoir pour vous expliquer notre projet
global d'avenir merci mes animaux
nathalie arthaud est ce que la nature
l'environnement le bien-être animal est
ce que ça fait partie de vos combats ou
est-ce que ça vous paraît secondaire
bien sûr que ça fait partie de mes
combats alors là c'est une archive de 74
vous prenez du monde voilà c'était quand
voilà les ait des candidats écolos en
même temps que la première candidature
eux voilà enfin de 14 alors vous voyez
souvent nous on nous accuse de
de dire et de répéter le même discours
depuis 30 ans depuis 40 ans depuis 50
ans mais je vois que lui c'est pas les
écologistes ils sont face à la même à la
même situation en fait 20 voiliers se
voit là il vient parce que parce que ce
système capitaliste 1 la réalité c'est
qu'ils exploitent les hommes autant
qu'ils exploitent la nature et ils les
exploitent jusqu'à leur extrême limite
jusqu'à les détruire
moi c'est ce qui me frappe dans cette
dans ce système là tout est bon pour
faire du fric tout alors bon on a vu le
scandale des ehpad vous avez vu même
même les derniers jours de notre vie
servent à faire du fric pour certains
mais la nature c'est pareil donc pour
moi c'est le même combat tout ça on peut
pas accepter que il y ait une minorité
capitaliste qui ne jurent que par leur
fric et après moi le déluge mais c'est
ça qui se passe c'est ces grandes
multinationales total mais dans
l'agroalimentaire c'est la même chose et
et moi ce que je ce que ce que j'ai
quand même envie de dire aujourd'hui
c'est que on leur fait confiance à eux à
ceux qui ont pollué à ceux qui ont
détruit la planète on leur fait
confiance pour que pour faire la
transition énergétique pour que demain
en fait enfin on respecte les ressources
naturelles on leur fait confiance mais
mais mais mais comment leur faire
confiance ce n'est pas possible ce n'est
pas possible alors moi oui je prétend
d'ailleurs dans cette campagne à voir le
programme le plus conséquent en matière
écologique pourquoi parce que je suis
pour l'expropriation de ses grandes
multinationales et pour qu'on les prenne
en main de façon collective et que pour
qu'on les fasse fonctionner non
seulement pour qu'elles répondent
d'abord aux besoins vitaux un des femmes
et des hommes et pas aux caprices de
quelques riches mais aussi pour qu elles
pour qu'elles puissent répond pour
qu'elle puisse préserver la planète pour
compte en considération effectivement et
bien
la limitation de ces de ses ressources
naturelles
dernier rubrique de cet adn une
rencontre
[Musique]
dans les archives de l'ina nous avons
trouvé une voie que nous voulons vous
faire entendre pour que vous puissiez en
quelque sorte dialoguer avec elle
nous sommes sur le plateau d'
apostrophes en 78 c'est jean marie
domenach philosophe directeur de la
revue esprit qui fait un lien entre le
totalitarisme et la religion il répond à
une question de bernard pivot
mesquer certainement on n'est pas crû
davantage en la révolution quand dieu ou
davantage c'était pas du même ordre
d'ailleurs pour moi ça allait un peu
ensemble un peu trop d'ailleurs je le
regrette maintenant
on pense que c'est une confusion
regrettable
je suis maintenant convaincu que le
totalitarisme est le fruit d' d'une
certaine passion religieuse frustré et
qui a d'ailleurs fêté malheureuse parce
que précisément les chrétiens n'ont pas
suivi donner une réponse elle
est ce que vous souscrivez à ces propos
je ne vois pas tellement le rapport avec
tout ce qu'on vient de discuter pourquoi
pourquoi me parlez-vous du totalitarisme
l'âge je ne vois pas le rapport en fait
voilà je
bien sûr je sais bien que pour beaucoup
l'idéal communiste
est assimilé avec
7,7 dictature stalinienne mais comme
vous l'avez rappelé mon courant c'est le
courant du trotskisme c'est à dire
précisément de ceux qui ont combattu à 7
cette dérive totalitaire 7,7 et qu'ils
ont expliqué qu'ils ont combattu et
qu'ils ont expliqué et qui ont permis de
dire que oui la révolution dans un seul
pays c'est ça peut pas être une
perspective on peut plus changer la
société en cours sur une nouvelle
île de façon isolée dans ses frontières
etc et que a par ailleurs une société
organisée collectivement il doit être
sur la démocratie sur la démocratie pour
moi c'est indissociable des idées
communistes dont vous voyez moi ce ce
combat de trotski ses explications de
trotski pour moi elles sont
fondamentales parce que en effet pour
moi c'est la seule façon aujourd'hui de
se revendiquer encore des idées
communistes d'être fidèle à cet idéal la
oublions le mot totalitarisme employés
par domenach et au fond ce qu'il ce
surcoût et d'insister sur la dimension
qui pouvait être religieuse de l'idéal
communiste non mais moi je vais vous
avez vous même grandi dans cette culture
là dans cette culture catholique parce
qu'ils fassent quelque chose maintenant
je ne croit plus en dieu moi depuis que
j'ai
16 17 ans en fait je ne crois je ne
crois pas en dieu et la grande
différence si vous voulez entre les
religions la croyance en dieu et 7,7
cette conviction profonde que l'homme
peut changer cette société prendre la
prendre en main la gérer collectivement
elle n'est pas appuyé don puisse rien
c'est pas c'est pas la foi du
charbonnier c'est que moi j'ai vu enfin
l'histoire l'histoire a vu des moments
d'insurrection de révolte ou les
travailleurs se sont organisés de façon
mais extrêmement démocratique de la
façon la plus large possible en
associant des millions de femmes et
d'hommes aux décisions moi je la commune
de paris c'est pas c'est ça a été une
réalité cette révolution russe dans ses
premiers mois cette capacité que les
travailleurs ont eu de faire surgir leur
comité de s'emparer et de régler eux
mêmes les problèmes de répondre à leurs
besoins ce sont des choses qui qui qui
ont existé qui ça a été des combats qui
ont été menées alors qu'ils n'ont pas
été menées au bout qui ont finalement
été défaits d'accord les
pour moi il ya énormément de page dans
l'histoire qui montrent en effet que on
peut aller à une société et on doit
aller vers une société
collective on doit se dire que
il n'y a aucune raison que la direction
de la société la direction politique la
direction économique d'une société soit
réservé une élite à une élite que cette
hiérarchie sociale que l'exploitation de
l'homme par l'homme
on
ce n'est pas pour l'éternité ce n'est
pas pour l'éternité bon moi je ce que je
vois c'est que la société humaine à la
traversée mais énormément de
d'organisation sociale et politique
différente qu'elle est sans cesse
évoluer le capitalisme lui-même il a un
début et il aura une fin il aura une fin
et cette fois ça doit être une fin
pour aller vers le mieux justement pour
dépasser cette société capitaliste mois
moi je pense en réalité qu'on n'a jamais
été aussi proche d'une société
communiste en arrière n'a jamais été
aussi proches pourquoi parce que parce
qu'on produit mais à une échelle
collectif parce qu'il ya des souhaits
concentration l'a12 de d'entreprise
ces mastodontes qui font que on est tous
il y a des centaines de milliers de
salariés qui sont réunis dans un même
système productif et bien c'est cette
logique là qu'il faut qu'il faut
finalement
poussé un poussé jusqu'au bout et donc
puisque ont produit ensemble puisqu'on
est coordonnée à l'échelle de la planète
à l'échelle internationale puisque notre
système productif il est interpellé très
et bien dirigeons une façon collective
dirigeants de façon collective mais
donnons la possibilité à ceux qui font
l'économie à ceux qui la portent sur
leurs épaules aux travailleurs qui
produisent toutes les richesses
justement de diriger de diriger
eux-mêmes collectivement et
démocratiquement c'est ça l'idée du
communisme de cet idéal là c'est en
réalité les germes du communisme ils
sont déjà dans cette société dans notre
société actuelle ils sont ils sont là et
sont en germe d'avoir cette conscience
voilà cette conscience qu'on n'ait pas
condamné à la dictature la de ce grand
capital qui décide à la place de tout le
monde un conte frais que si on avait
tous la possibilité de participer aux
décisions à cette société elle sera
organisée bien autrement dernière
question de ta liberté au terme de cet
entretien y at il un morceau essentiel
de votre adn que nous avons manqué
un morceau est essentielle
je fais ne
l'a dit comme ça non je ne crois pas
hier évoque la combativité la
détermination on a une politique en sait
ce qu'on veut
voilà
non je
ne crois pas je ne crois pas non moi moi
en plus cela on parle d' adn on parle
mais mais mon adn voilà il est collectif
et des collectifs voilà moi j'ai envie
vraiment que que cette
que cette idée elle domine par dessus
tout c'est que en fait là notre société
ce qu'on est ce qu'on essaie le fruit
c'est le fruit de
d'abord et avant tout d'une société
et que
l'individualisme le carriérisme c'est
c'est une impasse et on doit pas
raisonner et il faut pas raisonner comme
ça c'est une impasse pour tous et il
faut réaliser que voilà moi je pense
qu'il ya une société supérieur possible
voilà société supérieure pour cible avec
d'autres rapports entre les hommes mais
ça veut dire qui est plus cette
exploitation de l'homme par l'homme plus
ces classes sociales ya plus voilà il ya
même plus de raison d'être là en fait on
peut conserver une autre société voilà
produire de façon consciente et
démocratique c'est ça pour moi l'idéal
communiste merci d'apple lire tôt tu
veux remercier
[Musique]